last question today hey David do you
believe that Medicare for all should
cover elective cosmetic and plastic
surgery so I'm going to answer the
question as asked but then I'm going to
tell you that there's a major problem
with this question so during the debates
I often implore the Democratic
candidates to immediately call out
questions as problematic when they are
rather than answering them as asked this
is my show so I'll do it in the opposite
way I'm telling you the question is a
problem but first I'll answer it as
asked the term elective is the
complicating factor here it's pretty
widely accepted that cheek implants or
breast implants for medically
unnecessary elective cosmetic reasons
would not be covered by Medicare for all
that you find very little disagreement
with that now the counter-argument would
be you know some of these things are
medically unnecessary but someone's
appearance is causing them emotional
distress their nose is causing them
emotional distress and they're in
therapy because of their nose and it
should be covered for that reason it's
not the most convincing argument to me
but that is an argument that is
sometimes made then you get - well what
about cosmetic surgery that's the result
of injury or illness and most people say
that that should be covered by Medicare
for all and I completely agree when you
get to elective it can get pretty
complicated there can be lots of things
that are not medically necessary as
typically defined but they're not mere
vanity and the question then becomes
where do we draw the line at elective if
you need breast reconstruction from
breast cancer that's a definitive yes if
you want breast implants for vanity
typically that's a definitive no but
what about something like breast lift
surgery for a post pregnancy condition
that is not life-threatening and it's a
mix of medically suggested and for
physical appearance I don't know I mean
I lean - it should be covered but these
are the sort of middle of the
Road cases that end up becoming a debate
but now okay put all of that aside
here's the real analysis this is a
complete red herring used to distract
from the reality that people already now
are foregoing tons of medically
necessary and preventive maintenance
type procedures getting things looked at
before they become serious because of
the system that we have and we already
have private insurers making decisions
about what is and isn't covered so the
problem I have with this question about
whether or not elective cosmetic surgery
would be covered under Medicare for all
is that it's an attempt to attack
Medicare for all by saying either wow
you would cover cosmetic surgery that's
crazy my taxes shouldn't pay for your
nose job or oh you won't cover it well
it's not really universal coverage is it
and this is the game we shouldn't be
drawn into it's a complete distraction
I'm more than glad to have the
conversation here on the show because
I'm answering your questions and telling
you what I think but this is a complete
and total distraction from the fact that
even if these questions about cosmetic
surgery remain countless other issues
are resolved by Medicare for all and we
already have the same type of issues
that people are describing about edge
case middle-of-the-road
elective cosmetic surgery so don't allow
yourself to fall for what is quite
frankly a distraction from the real
debate as to what kind of health care
system we should have in the United
States that does it for questions today
send yours in tweet them to me at D
Pakman send them to me with the subject
line audience questions by using the
contact form at david pakman.com I'll
answer three more next week and make
sure to join me on the bonus show today
become a member at join pakman.com or a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show to get instant access to the bonus
show which is coming up right after this